[Music]
drake is with us in kansas city hi drake
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
well pretty much i
was lucky enough to live with the best
dad
anybody could ever ask for
best friend growing up all that long
story short he passed away a few years
ago and
left me a pretty good chunk
of money
it's in a trust fund right now
i won't see any of it until i'm 25
i'm a college student right now i'm 22
so i've got about three years left to go
uh basically i have a few ideas of kind
of
what i should do and how i should save
it investments like real estate and
stuff like that down the road
but pretty much i just wanted to see
kind of if you were me
or if you were in my shoes what what
were
what would be some things you would do
with a big chunk like this how much is
it
um i've got about
550 000 in 401k
and then about 438 in calf
and i've got about
18
18 000 in my own right now that i have
access to okay
and you're 22 how old was he
uh he was
53 when he passed away wow what happened
yeah
um
sadly it was a
terminal disease um lou gehrig's disease
so it was yeah
i'm sure uh pretty rough yeah i'm sorry
for you sorry for what you've been
through yeah okay i appreciate that but
uh yeah a couple of things i mean more
than anything you just need some
principles to guide you
okay instead of specific tactics let me
give you some principles
number one principle go slow
there's no reason to be fast
number two don't put money in anything
you don't understand
just because somebody says it they know
this or they know that or you read an
article on the internet god help you
don't do that
um or because even dave ramsey said to
do it don't do it you don't put money in
something unless you
understand it
if you understand it you can learn from
people like me
to where you understand it then you can
go forward but just because it's shiny
and flashy and cool and the cool kids
are all doing it does not mean you put
money in it as a matter of fact that
usually means you don't
um the other thing you can remember is
this having studied wealthy people for
the past 30 years
i find that their investing strategies
are by and large very boring
they're not super uber sophisticated
they don't do uh you know limited family
partnership double back flips there's no
weird stuff all these things you hear
that the rich have secrets they really
don't
they go slow
they know what they put money in they
understand it they don't put money in
something unless they understand it and
therefore they don't lose it and it
generally makes some money but they're
not trying to hit the home run every
time they're just trying to make money
on their money
just steady right and so uh it doesn't
matter what you put money in as long as
you understand it and you know you know
what it is and you do it so um
you know so i know a lot about real
estate i grew up in the real estate
business my parents were in the business
when i was a kid i got my license when i
turned 18. i'm very very comfortable
with real estate consequently i have a
bunch of it
okay right but someone who's scared to
death and has never done it or never
dealt with a tenant you would want to go
super super slow
test it a little bit test it a little
bit test it a little bit it's second
nature for me though
okay
same thing with mutual funds i i really
do not have any investments personally
except mutual funds and real estate
that's all i have okay because i got
really comfortable with it doesn't have
to be sexy or cool if the cool kids
don't like it i don't really care i'm
not investing for them
right you know yeah ramsey doesn't
understand dave ramsey's got several
hundred million dollars dave ramsey
understands something okay all right so
um you know that that's just
you know that that's but that's what i
find when i talk to
you know uh you know you're the person
you're talking to if they've got a
little gray hair it's probably a good
idea
uh because i i was young and rich and
lost everything i didn't want his
opinion when i started surveying people
about how money works because he was an
idiot he lost everything that's me i'm
talking about so
but i did i did high leverage get rich
quick real estate and it bit me in the
butt
uh because i've violated a lot of common
sense rules so all of that to say do
that the last thing i'll tell you is
this in the multitude of council there
is safety
and so if i were a 25 year old
millionaire sudden sudden millionaire
i would uh build a board of directors
for my life not that tells me what to do
a board of advisors i'd have a high
quality insurance broker an estate
planner
a tax attorney
an investment broker
all that i can call and speak to
about taxes about insurance about real
estate a good real estate person i'd
have a little collection of people that
i i you don't necessarily have to call
them all together at any time but they
need to um they're there to advise you
with the heart of a teacher they're not
there to tell you what to do they're not
there to be arrogant and act like they
have their god's gift to whatever
um
the if you get if you sense that
arrogance run from them
but get some teachers in your corner
because you have to go slow and you have
to invest only in things you don't
understand
the one that you do understand the one
thing i'd add dave is i didn't
understand this until
i got older and started having money
don't don't use this money to leverage
this money to go get some more yeah
the number of folks who said hey you
want to put 10 in on this or 25 in on
this or hey we're all going in to buy
this apartment you want to put 15 on
this
they they like me as a friend but what
they really want is my money to make
their picture of what they want to do
come true and it's easy to take that
money and think you can parse it out and
make a bunch of people happy and make a
bunch of money every you end up
spreading it all out and you end up wait
you can lose that money quick yeah right
i i the only ship on sale is a
partnership i'm not in any partnerships
i own it or i'm not in it it's okay and
that means i got lots of friends that do
all kinds of stuff like that but i don't
i don't do it i'm just my life is low
drama
very low drama right it's just downright
boring
you know and i kind of like it that way
that's right it wasn't intentional